- This chess lawsuit is ass. Or is it?
It all started when 31-year-old
Grandmaster Magnus Carlsen of Norway,
the top-ranked chess player in the world,
was dealt a rare tournament
defeat by Hans Niemann,
a 19-year-old American prodigy,
ranked 40th in the world,
who, some have dubbed
the "Bad Boy of Chess",
due to his oddly combative
demeanor in interviews.
- Well, this is completely
(beep) ridiculous
that the laptop is just
running outta power.
Like, plug the (beep) laptop in.
- Carlsen then shocked the chess world
by accusing Neimann of
repeatedly cheating in matches.
These voices only grew
louder after Chess.com,
the world's largest online
chess platform concluded
after a week's long investigation,
that Neimann had cheated in
more than 100 online games,
then banned him from the platform.
This wild tale has all
the makings of a drama fit
for a future Netflix series.
Especially given the
salacious Internet rumors
that Neimann cheated with the help
of an adult entertainment device
put in an adult entertainment location.
This method of cheating, of course,
was pioneered by the famous international
Grandmaster, Ben Wa.
Now, Neimann has vehemently
denied the cheating allegations
and responded to this controversy the way
that almost guarantees that
you end up on this channel.
By filing a $100 million
lawsuit accusing the critics
of defamation,
and colluding to blacklist him from play
and destroy his career.
So let's take a dive into
the Neimann cheating scandal.
We'll break down the claims
leveled against Neimann, his response,
and whether the $100
million dollar lawsuit
has any chance of success,
or whether he's going
to need a silver bullet.
Now, all of this drama
began on September 4th,
when Neimann and Carlsen faced
off at the Sinquefield Cup
in St. Louis.
Despite being the lowest ranked
player in the tournament,
Neimann pulled off a stunning
upset against Carlsen
in the third round,
snapping the world champ's
53-match winning streak.
In a post-match interview,
Neimann was less than gracious.
- I think he's just so demoralized
because he's losing to such
an idiot like me, you know?
It's just, it must be embarrassing
for the world champion to lose to me.
I feel bad for him.
- Neimann attributed his
victory to a ridiculous miracle
that he happened to study
the rare chess opening
Carlsen used the morning before the game,
allowing Neimann to guess
how Carlsen would start.
- That's them (beep).
Ah, that's them (beep) right there.
- Carlsen's move the next day
was an even more unusual variation.
Pulling out of the tournament
for the first time in his career,
and only providing context
with a veiled tweet.
Grandmaster and chess
streamer, Hikaru Nakamura,
interpreted Carlsen's tweet
as a veiled accusation
that Neimann was a cheater.
And that this was the reason
for Carlsen's withdrawal,
after the loss to Neimann.
- At the end of the day, there's nothing.
There's nothing. Nothing is proven.
But there is a lot of suspicion.
There is a lot of suspicion.
- Neimann has a history of
cheating online on Chess.com,
and was banned there, twice.
Though Neimann has denied
cheating since his last ban
when he was 16,
and has stated that he has
never cheated in in-person game,
or when prize money was involved.
- I've never, ever in
my life cheated in an
over-the-board game, in online tournament.
They were an unrated games.
- Following a game on September 19th,
in which Carlsen resigned
after the first three moves
in apparent protest, the next day,
Carlsen implicitly accused
Neimann of cheating
and declared he was unwilling to play
against people that have
cheated in the past.
Carlsen tweeted that Neimann's
"Over-the-board progress has been unusual
and throughout our game
in the Sinquefield Cup,
I had the impression that he wasn't tense,
or even fully concentrating on the game
in critical positions, while
outplaying me as black,
in a way I think only a
handful of players can do.
This game contributed to
changing my perspective."
On October 4th, Chess.com released
a bombshell 72-page report,
"Concluded that Neimann
has cheated much more
than he has publicly admitted to,
including in many prize events,
at least 25 streamed games,
and 100-plus rated games on Chess.com,
as recently as when he was 17 years old."
These findings contradicted
Neimann's public claims
that he only cheated twice,
that he never cheated
in prize money events,
and that he stopped
cheating at the age of 16.
In support of their findings,
Chess.com used a variety of
cheating detection tools,
including a comparative
analysis of the moves made,
versus the moves recommended
by supercomputers,
a player's past performance
and known strength profile,
the statistical
significance of the results,
and input from grandmaster analysis.
While Chess.com concedes that
"there was no direct evidence"
that Neimann cheated in his
win at the Sinquefield Cup,
the report did highlight
some suspicious elements.
Specifically, the report
addressed Neimann's
apparent struggle to discuss the rationale
of his own chess strategy
after beating Carlsen in St. Louis,
which top players at the time described as
at odds with the level of preparation
that Hans claimed was at play in the game,
and the level of analysis needed to defeat
the world chess champion.
But, one might ask, how does
a person even cheat at chess?
Before this story broke,
you might have been
surprised to see the words
"chess" and "cheating"
in the same sentence.
But in the words of the Washington Post,
"Chess has long been a game rife
with allegations of
chicanery in skullduggery."
- This, this chicanery!
- As technology has advanced, so too,
have chess cheating methodologies.
These days, people have been
caught using chess engines,
computer programs that analyze games
to recommend the strongest possible moves.
Chess engines are so
advanced that they can beat
even the best grandmasters,
every single time.
- Mate, in 143 moves.
- No, pooh, you win again!
- And in a video entitled,
"Is This Proof that Hans Neimann Cheated?"
Nakamura reacted to a video
from French streamer, Yosha Iglésias,
discussing a third-party
statistical analysis of 10 games,
where Neimann's chess play achieved
a near 100 percent correlation
to the perfect moves of a chess engine.
According to the analysis,
no other players,
not even Carlsen, boasts
so many 100 percent games.
And recently, players
have been caught cheating
using chess engines on their smartphones.
Like Georgian Grandmaster Gaioz Nigalidze,
who, at 25 years old, was caught cheating
at the 2015 Dubai Open,
using a chess engine on
the smartphone he hid
in the bathroom stall.
Nigalidze's Grandmaster title was revoked
and he was banned from
competition for three years.
But what happens if you
can't access your smartphone?
Well, one particularly
salacious rumor began
to circulate on Reddit
that Neimann could have
cheated using a well-placed
Wi-Fi connected vibrating
adult entertainment device.
Now, to be clear,
there is absolutely zero
evidence that this happened.
It's just a Reddit rumor.
Though, it is technically
possible to cheat this way.
But for more on this,
let's go to one of YouTube's
resident chess experts
at Gotham Chess,
to explain more about
these cheating allegations.
- Hey everyone, I'm Levy Rozman,
also known as Gotham Chess.
And I've got the largest
chess channel here on YouTube.
Thanks so much, Legal Eagle,
for featuring me in this video.
I'll try to answer all the
questions as best as I can,
even though I'm here in a hotel room.
So, I'm sorry if the setup
isn't as good as yours.
There have been players in the
past, like Barislov Ivanov,
who was found with a device in his shoe.
That device was somehow
registering good moves
and vibrating to indicate to him
something about the chess board.
Maybe it was Morse code,
maybe it was something else.
There was another case.
I believe it was the French
Olympic team in 2010.
There was a whole elaborate system.
Somebody sitting at home
was watching the game live, broadcasted.
That person was then relaying
something to a middle man,
who was then standing in a certain corner
of the room itself,
to relay information to the person
that was playing at the board.
- Let's think about a very
simple representation.
I would need two squares.
- [Off-Screen Voice] Mm hmm.
- The first, to designate which piece,
and the second, where the piece is moving.
That's probably the easiest.
What's the smallest amount of information
you need to help you?
- Basically like a buzz,
in a critical position.
That would be good.
- And what would the buzz say?
- It would, it'd basically,
it'd be something like one
buzz means the position
is great, and two buzzes means
the position is completely,
it's completely equal.
Or there's nothing
special in the position.
- Now, Neimann vehemently
denies the cheating allegations,
even colorfully offering
to strip naked before games
to prove he's not hiding anything.
- They could literally tell
me the most ridiculous thing.
They want me to strip fully naked.
I'll do it, I don't care.
- [Host] And well, so far
he's not played in the nude.
He, along with the other players,
was subject to a full body
scan with a metal detector
at the US Chess Championship in St. Louis.
Which takes us to October 20th,
when Neimann made his next move
by filing a federal lawsuit
against Magnus Carlsen,
Carlsen's chess company,
"Play Magnus", Nakamura, Chess.com,
and Chess.com executive, Danny Rensch.
The complaint demands
at least $100 million
in damages from the defendants,
arising out of causes of action
for slander, libel, unlawful group boycott
under the Sherman Antitrust Act,
tortious interference
with Neimann's business,
and civil conspiracy.
The 44-page complaint is
primarily a recounting
of public statements made by
Carlsen, Rensch and Nakamura.
Though it notably does
not address any salacious,
or unsubstantiated Internet rumors.
Neimann asserts that there is
no truth to the allegations
that he cheated at the
Sinquefield Cup, claiming that
"Unbiased top chess
analysts have concluded
that his victory resulted more
from Carlsen's particularly poor play,
than Neimann's exceptional play."
The complaint also calls
Chess.com's cheating report
a "false and malicious hatchet job
full of slanted analysis."
And that the report's statement
of Neimann's privately confessing
to additional cheating offenses
to Danny Rensch, is false.
The complaint is full of effusive praise
for the "American chess
prodigy, Hans Neimann",
and vitriolic insults
for the other defendants.
For example, the lawsuit claims that a
"corrupt and cowardly"
Carlsen chose to viciously
and maliciously defame Neimann
with false cheating allegations,
due to his "inability to cope with defeat"
at the Sinquefield Cup,
after a man 12 years his junior
"dared to disrespect the King of Chess."
The complaint accuses Nakamura of joining
in this defamatory conspiracy
because he viewed Neimann as a
"threat to Nakamura's dominance
on chess streaming platforms."
The complaint also accuses Chess.com
of colluding with Carlsen
because the company plans
to purchase Carlsen's
"Play Magnus" app for nearly $83 million,
in a merger Neimann claims will
monopolize the chess world.
Though this merger was
announced in August,
before the cheating allegations.
Neimann also alleges
the defendants violated
the Sherman Antitrust Act of 1890,
which outlaws certain
monopolistic business practices
by colluding to blacklist
Neimann with false
and defamatory cheating allegations
that "by design, destroyed
Neimann's remarkable career
in its prime and ruined his life."
Neimann also alleges that
"defendants acted in concert
to improperly refuse to deal
with Neimann, including
Chess.com banning Neimann
from its platform, and sponsored events,
Carlsen refusing to play Neimann
in any tournaments or events
and defendants acting
collectively to cause organizers
of professional chess
tournaments to blacklist Neimann
from participating in their events."
So, the $100 million question.
Can Neimann win this case?
Well, among legal observers,
the emerging consensus is
that Neimann faces an uphill battle.
So let's start with the prayer for relief.
Neimann seeks $100 million in damages.
And while that's certainly
a jaw-dropping number,
it has zero basis in reality.
He certainly pulled
that one out of his ass.
Whenever someone files a lawsuit,
they can put any number they want.
And in a complaint like this,
that serves, potentially,
to recover damages,
but also serves to try
and rehabilitate someone's reputation,
it's there to grab headlines,
which it certainly did.
But in a case like this,
any prayer for relief,
whether it's $1 or $100 million dollars,
means absolutely nothing.
But let's move on to the
rest of this lawsuit,
and start with jurisdiction.
Because Neimann has to
show why federal courts
in St. Louis even have
jurisdiction to decide this matter.
And the fact that Neimann
filed suit in Missouri
raises all kinds of questions.
To hear a case, a court has to have
both personal jurisdiction, and
subject matter jurisdiction.
Now, subject matter
jurisdiction is the requirement
that a court has the power to
hear a specific kind of claim.
And for the moment, it
seems that the courts
having federal jurisdiction
might make sense
because the complaint at
the moment asserts a claim
for a violation of the
Sherman Antitrust Act,
which is a federal law.
And there might be something
called diversity jurisdiction,
given the residency of
all of the defendants.
But there's also the personal
jurisdiction requirement
that a court has power
over the defendants,
based on usually what's called
"minimum contacts with that forum."
And the most common way to
get personal jurisdiction
over a person, or a business,
is to sue them where they live,
or do business, or
where the tort occurred.
But here, it's entirely
possible that some,
or all the defendants could
get this suit dismissed,
at least without prejudice.
Meaning that the suit could be refiled,
given their lack of
connection to St. Louis.
Now, Neimann lives in Connecticut.
Nakamura lives in Florida.
Carlsen and his company are from Norway,
and Chess.com is a Nevada LLC,
while Rensch lives in Utah.
The only one with any links
to Missouri is Carlsen,
who allegedly made the defamatory
remarks that first arose
out of his defeat in the
Sinquefield Cup in St. Louis.
So why would Neimann sue in Missouri,
instead of his home in Connecticut?
Well, some have speculated that it's
because of Connecticut's
strong anti-SLAPP statute,
which dismisses lawsuits
that are brought simply
to retaliate against defendants'
exercising of free speech.
Which would've required
Neimann to show evidence
for every single element of his claims
against every single
defendant to avoid dismissal.
And in contrast,
Missouri's anti-SLAPP laws
basically non-existent,
and it only applies to
comments at public hearings.
Which certainly wouldn't
stop Neimann's suit.
So let's talk about
Neimann's defamation claims.
If you haven't seen are
dozens of videos tackling
the topic of defamation.
Defamation is a tort that
creates civil liability
for false statements that injure
a third party's reputation.
Neimann has sued the
defendants for slander,
which is verbal defamation,
and libel, written defamation.
But there's several
barriers that could make
these claims hard to win,
even if the cheating allegations
are proven to be untrue.
For starters, defamation
is only actionable
if a defendant makes a false
statement of verifiable fact,
meaning the assertion must be capable
of definitively being
proven true, or false.
And opinions, are by
nature, not defamatory,
if they merely express
these speakers' commentary,
based on public information.
And here, Carlsen accusing
Neimann of cheating after losing
at the Sinquefield Cup is
probably not an assertion of fact,
but a opinion based on disclosed fact.
And as some have said,
"It may be a stupid opinion.
It may be a wrong opinion.
But it's an opinion,
a conclusion reached based
on the observed play,
not a statement of fact.
It can't be defamatory."
And to prevail, Neimann
would have to prove
that Carlsen didn't actually
think Neimann cheated
when he made those claims.
A very high, if not
impossible bar to clear.
Similarly, Nakamura may be
shielded from defamation claims
to the extent that he's
only giving his opinion
and commentary on
Neimann's alleged cheating,
based on public facts.
And not to fear, the same
goes for a legal commentary,
YouTube channel giving legal commentary
on a chess cheating scandal.
But the complaint does suggest
that Chess.com's conclusion
that Neimann cheated, is
based on undisclosed facts.
And sometimes implying undisclosed facts,
or explicitly stating that
there are undisclosed facts,
can lead to defamation.
And the Chess.com report alleges
that Neimann "privately confessed
to additional cheating offenses",
in a private August, 2020 phone call
with Chess.com's, Danny Rensch,
which the complaint denies.
However, the Chess.com report
does include private communications
between Neimann and Rensch,
between August, 2020
and January, 2021, that shows
the Zoom call took place.
Neimann acknowledging
being banned for cheating,
and calling said consequences
"completely fair."
And that's certainly going to
hurt Neimann's credibility,
unless he can show that those
private messages were faked,
or taken out of context.
Another potential barrier to recovery,
Neimann's fame and notoriety means
that he could be classified
as a public figure,
subject to the heightened
actual malice standard.
To prove actual malice, which, again,
has nothing to do with hating someone,
one must prove that the
statements were made
with knowledge of being false,
or reckless disregard for
their truth or falsity.
The actual malice standard also applies
to limited purpose public figures,
which refers to one who
voluntarily participates
in a discussion about a
particular controversy
and has access to the media to
get his, or her views across.
This is opposed to the normal standard,
which is just negligence with
respect to false statements.
But Neimann's almost-Trumpian praise
of how famous and successful he is,
that's contained in the complaint,
only reinforces the idea
that he should be treated
as a public figure, subject
to the actual malice standard.
But that's a double-edged sword,
because this complaint is
potentially to redress grievances
in court, and get damages.
But it's also supposed
to try to rehabilitate
Neimann's own reputation,
and get eyeballs on it.
So, it goes both ways.
But, given this high standard of proof,
Neimann might not have any luck
against Chess.com in court.
And as Bloomberg columnist
Stephen L. Carter points out,
"lawsuits by individuals
accused of cheating,
have mostly been unsuccessful with courts
often unwilling to second guess
a gaming organization's own
findings of wrongdoing."
As an example, Carter cites
to a 2010 Indiana case,
where a golf teaching pro
unsuccessfully sued a colleague
for calling him "a cheat"
for claiming a different classification
than the one to which he was entitled.
In that case, the Professional
Golf Association agreed
with the colleague's allegations
following an investigation
and the court dismissed
the defamation claim
because the statements were true.
As Carter notes, the court
didn't do its own investigation.
Rather, the organization's
own judgment was sufficient
to shield the defendant from liability.
And doubly so, it's
hard to win an antitrust
and intentional interference
claim in the absence
of prevailing on a defamation claim.
And those remaining causes of action
are also not particularly strong,
based on the allegations
made in the complaint.
For antitrust claims, in this context,
it's likely that Neimann would
have to plead enough facts
to convince a jury that if true,
the defendants entered
into an actual agreement
to blacklist Neimann.
But Neimann and Chess.com
are not competitors,
and complaining that Chess.com and Carlsen
won't voluntarily play with him,
doesn't necessarily establish
an illegal agreement.
And simply alleging that the defendants
did similar things, at the same time,
isn't enough to allege an
agreement in restraint of trade.
And additionally, tortious
interference allows for a claim
for damages when a defendant
wrongfully interferes
with an existing contractual,
or business relationship.
The key there being wrongful interference
with an existing contractual relationship.
The complaint makes conclusory allegations
that the defendants
intentionally interfered
with Neimann's relationship with a series
of chess-related entities,
to coerce them to terminate
the relationships with him,
and blacklist him from future trade.
But these are tough claims to make,
because the complaint
doesn't actually allege
any conduct directed at these entities.
And to prevail on a civil
conspiracy cause of action,
a plaintiff has to prove that
two or more defendants, again,
entered into an agreement
to commit a wrong,
and did actually commit a
tortious act in furtherance
of that agreement that caused
injury to a third party.
And Neimann makes conclusory allegations
that the defendants agreed to
do bad stuff to hurt Neimann,
but doesn't actually
provide the factual basis
suggesting an agreement to do that.
In quoting Texas Judge John Chupp,
"Three people all liking
the same cat picture
on the Internet is not a conspiracy."
But the thing about real conspiracies
is that you rarely have evidence
of that agreement at face value.
So, if this lawsuit does
make it past the motion
to dismiss stage, into discovery,
I'm sure the very first thing
that Neimann will ask for,
are all communications
related to agreements
between all of these parties.
And who knows, maybe
those agreements exist.
But to understand whether Neimann cheated
or whether Carlsen is being a sore loser,
it would really help to
understand statistics
and probability.
And today's sponsor, Brilliant,
is exactly the place to help.
Brilliant is an online
learning platform for STEM
that replaces lecture videos
with hands-on interactive lessons.
Brilliant is for curious
learners, both young and old,
professional and inexperienced.
And you can quickly learn
to ace your high school
college math course,
or just learn stuff
that you always wanted.
And in fact,
Brilliant's Data Science
Foundations course starts
with probability fundamentals,
and builds up to using
data and predictions,
experimentation and neural networks.
You'll learn and understand in
introduction to probability,
applied probability,
statistics, fundamentals,
and eventually, an introduction
into neural networks.
And then you can tell
me if Neimann cheated,
because Brilliant lets you learn by doing,
rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures.
Learning through doing
is scientifically proven
to be the most effective
way to master any new skill.
And the courses have storytelling,
interactive challenges,
and problems to solve.
You can sign up and start
learning for free today,
by going to Brilliant.org/LegalEagle,
or clicking on the link
that's on-screen right now,
or down in the description.
The first 200 people to sign up
will also get 20 percent off
their annual subscription.
So, by clicking on the link
that's on-screen right now,
or in the description,
you'll get 20 percent off your
subscription to Brilliant.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And after that, click on this
box for more Legal Eagle,
or I'll see you in court.